I understand your films have screened in
Sundance or a film of yours who screamed
something Sundance's all right no no I
just came back from Sundance I had a
couple of friends who had films there I
was just just supporting this here and
you know I produced independent film as
well as acting them so you know it's
always good to go out and support a
couple of my friends after this year
okay sorry about that so so knowing that
you are part of sort of the Sundance
machine or you've been there who've seen
it and so many indie filmmakers strive
for that sundance premiere they always
think they're going to get it you think
it's realistic for a lot of people to
try for it or maybe try smaller
festivals and and spread themselves out
further I don't know if I'm being clear
with that but do you think that's a
really thing yeah you know it's funny
I've produced two features now and we've
both for both of our features we
submitted the Sundance we didn't get in
so you know we're right in the thick of
that you know those those those Tomatoes
trying to get in you know I've been a
couple years in a row now to try to see
what i can find in trends and types of
films that they look for you know
realistically you know it always like
anything else whether it's theaters it's
moving it's TV it's always a script it
starts at the script you know you have
to have a great script and everything
else falls into place and I think I
think you always have to try right if
you don't try you don't get you know and
you i think really being focused and and
bringing good people on board your
project you have a better shot you know
Sundance likes to bring back a lot of
their past alums so I've noticed a lot
of people embrace and bringing certain
crew members that have you know whether
they're cast or crew
been in a film were involved with a film
that was at the festival so you know
there are little things you can try to
view along the way to embrace and
hopefully you know catch the eye oh
right and are you ever planning to use
crowdfunding to find any of your budgets
you know we haven't for any of our
features we have been a couple of short
films and stuff that I've helped produce
that that we did use crowdfunding for
for features you know it's it's a very
realistic possibility I mean there's so
much that that is you know what's coming
in the way of crowdfunding there's a
site called film break that I have a
film that we are sort of developing with
them as a tentpole project and it's sort
of a different approach to crowdfunding
where this is it sort of generated
through social media your awareness and
your tracking and through them they have
compiled a list of investors and people
that want to invest in film so you know
it's instead of campaigning to get you
no money you're campaigning to get the
attention and sort of just the social
media following that will then turn over
and hopefully into funding from other
people so there's all sorts of new
companies like that developing and I
think that's you know it's kind of an
interesting way to because you don't
always have to be held by an investor or
obligated to that because you know you
have their perks that you would you give
out but aside from that you know
you're not you know creatively I think
artists like the fact that they're not
held back by an investor you know saying
you have to do this or have to put that
person in the film you know right can an
independent filmmaker be too independent
for their own good I don't know I don't
know what that means really I'm sure
every you know I think if you're doing
it you're doing it you know that's
that's the hard thing there especially
in today's society you know it's one of
the things I always tell my friends it's
like and the only reason that we're
producing films now because it's like I
knew a lot of people that had various
talents and different things and it was
like there should never be a moment
where we're not working because you know
especially with today you know in
technology and cameras and everything
it's even on a consumer level it's so
cheap to get professional quality so i
think it's always possible to do stuff
and that for me you know i always
embrace just keep working thank you very
much